Oh
thank you so much
Larry ah
I know I know I know why you're excited
you're excited because there are now 10
Republicans running for president isn't
that awesome
that clown car is filling up yeah
you know who got in it this week Rick
Perry member Rick Perry from 2012 yeah
we all remember 2012 Rick Perry but Rick
says I am NOT that guy at all anymore in
fact he says call me Caitlin really
wants to get away from it
oh why even pretend we're even gonna
talk about anything else that's what
America is obsessed with this week is
Caitlyn Jenner coming out on the cover
of Vanity Fair and you know what if he
she uh you know what pronoun police had
be going to climb up my ass
while you're up there you can kiss it
okay it's gonna take a minute to get you
so but if she makes people accept people
who are different
great then she's done a great thing but
let's also remember this is a husband
from reality TV who got breast implants
okay this is someone who used to be Kim
Kardashian's stepfather Otis now Kim
Kardashian's stepmother she's not Rosa
Parks but I'm glad she's happy and boy
it's working out what she already has a
endorsement deal with MAC Cosmetics and
did you see the Vanity Fair cover she
looks pretty awesome maybe they use the
MAC Cosmetics and I think this would be
very good for MAC Cosmetics oh I'm gonna
buy stock in mac cosmetics
I you know can i conceal my crow's feet
lady this ship made a 65 year old former
dude look like Brooke Shields
also this is the oldest woman 65 to
appear solo on the cover of Vanity Fair
which I think sends a very powerful
message that you can be a sexy glamorous
senior woman and all you need is
strength determination and a dick
oh yeah she keeping the dick
he's got boobs but keeping the penis
should have changed her name to spoiler
alert what proxies she's not whopping
off he's adding on it try to get the
permits out here it's hit that anyway
this is not but this is not going over
well with everybody on the right you
know Rush Limbaugh he says you know
they're redefining normalcy I say great
yeah for the better but you know what
Rush says if you want to make your penis
disappear do it the old way like I did
have your belly fat cover it up
I tell you it seems like everything in
the news this week was about sex this
week the FDA has endorsed Female Viagra
did you see that they go yeah they have
a pill that's not you know sugarcoat
this that makes women horny and the
experts are already calling it a huge
step forward for lazy unattractive
husbands and a big week for child
molesters don't applaud that I
appreciate the audience's enthusiasm but
we don't not we're just saying it's a
big week well it is I mean things got
worse for Denis has to be been reading
about Denis has to former Speaker of the
House who was also a wrestling coach in
the 70s and apparently was doing a
little more than wrestling with the boys
and a woman came forward today and said
her brother was one of the victims and
you know of course Dennis Hastert a
Republican and a bit of a hypocrite he
had a hundred percent approval rating
from the Christian Coalition huge
opponent of gay rights which is
something I've always said if if
anti-gay stuff is always coming out of
your mouth something very gay is
probably going in
also also I must say wrestling as gay as
the Greeks who invented it and anyone
who wants to be doing it with children
we should keep an eye on I mean the
first hint that Dennis Hastert was up to
something a little weird is when he
would pin you he'd say say uncle when
they did that he'd say now call me daddy
see they're right there I think is a red
flag and of course you're familiar with
the Duggar family right uh their reality
show 19 and groping you see okay how
many of you watched that show oh don't
tell me who gets molested on taping but
apparently when when Josh Duggar was a
teenager he inappropriately touched four
of his younger sisters and the
babysitter who we apologized to he said
I'm sorry I thought you were one of my
sister well to be fair you can't turn
around in that house without
inappropriately touching somebody is 19
of these freaks
and two and two of the four sisters were
on Fox tonight vigorously defended the
brother and endorsed Hastert for
president what what is it with white
people and molesting but after the Pinet
this after the parents found out about
this activity they put locks on the
sister's bedroom doors you know the
person who should have had a lock on the
door the wife the wife 19 children but
here's the it's their cover story is
that they not I guess what they're
saying is that the Josh just touched the
girls over their clothes while they were
sleeping he didn't do something really
terrible like try to sell a wedding cake
to a homo and just thought they were
sleeping what's the big test of all they
were sleeping and if they'd wake up he'd
just go quick impression Bill Cosby